salut silvio j'espère que vous allez
bien on continue de se plonger dans le
programme de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour se
plonger dans le programme de fabien
roussel le candidat du parti communiste
français
le tout en dix mesures l'idée ça vous
donne donc un bon aperçu de ce qu'il
propose sachant que comme pour tous les
candidats ça vient en complément de son
interview qui va sortir dans quelques
jours sur cette même chaîne youtube du
kun n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour
développer cette interview face cachée
de fabien roussel et des autres
candidats
alors comme d'habitude commençons par
une petite présentation fabien roussel à
52 ans il a d'abord été journaliste au
journal l'humanité un journal de gauche
mais a également été journaliste à
france télévisions il milite aussi a
depuis très jeune au sein du parti
communiste français en 2017 il est élu
député du nord et aujourd'hui il se
présente pour la première fois à
l'élection présidentielle on notera par
ailleurs que c'est aussi la première
fois depuis 2007 que le parti communiste
français présente un candidat en effet
en 2012 et en 2017 le pcf avait préféré
soutenir jean luc mélenchon voilà pour
la présentation et sans plus tarder
voyons ensemble les dix mesures de son
programme première mesure fabien roussel
souhaite je cite révolutionner le
travail et les résume cela par la
formule travailler tous travailler moins
travailler mieux pour cela il veut
augmenter immédiatement le salaire
minimum donc le smic pour le passé à
1500 euros net par mois contre 1200 sont
9 euros nets en ce moment cette
augmentation ces 100 euros de plus que
ce que propose jean luc mélenchon le
candidat de la france insoumise mais
c'est 300 euros de moins que ce que
propose philippe poutou le candidat du
nouveau parti anticapitaliste qui
souhaite lui donc le porter à 1800 euros
fabien roussel souhaite également
instaurer la semaine de travail de 32
heures sans diminution de salaire contre
donc les 35 heures qui sont en place
aujourd'hui l'objectif étant de répartir
mieux le travail au sein de la
population pour éviter que des gens se
retrouvent sans emploi enfin fabien
roussel veut aussi abaissé l'âge de
départ à la retraite à taux plein à 60
ans comme jean luc mélenchon philippe
plus tôt ou encore nathalie arthaud il
souhaite aussi permettre à ceux qui ont
un travail pénible de pouvoir partir
plus tôt 2 et mesure absolument majeure
dans le programme de fabien roussel
c'est le fait de remettre et réinvestir
dans les services publics il veut
augmenter par exemple le budget de
l'éducation nationale de 45 % ce qui
représente 25 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires et celui de
l'enseignement supérieur de 43% par
ailleurs plus largement il propose le
recrutement de 500 mille fonctionnaires
parmi eux il y aurait 100 mille emplois
dans l'hôpital avec surtout des
infirmiers des aides soignants ou encore
des aides à domicile il souhaite aussi
recruter 100 mille personnes dans les
maisons de retraite ainsi que 90 mille
emplois d'enseignants en parallèle le
salaire de tous les fonctionnaires donc
les personnes employées par l'état
seraient augmentées pour que les
enseignants par exemple et une
augmentation de salaire de 30% c'est une
augmentation qui serait supérieure à
celle de 20% souhaité par yannick jadot
mais inférieures au doublement de
salaires vers lequel veut aller anne
hidalgo pour ce qui est donc des
enseignants troisième mesure désormais
proposée par fabien roussel et qui
concerne cette fois ci précisément la
jeunesse il veut créer un revenu
étudiants de 850 euros par mois minimum
c'est un revenu en fait qui serait
versée à tous les étudiants sans
conditions peu importe le revenu de
leurs parents etc pour leur permettre au
fait d'être plus autonomes et de mieux
vivre pendant leurs études et si fabien
roussel est élu l'accès au revenu de
solidarité active donc le rsa une aide
sociale à destination des plus démunis
seraient réellement étendu aussi aux 18
25 ans d'une mesure là aussi qui est
porté par un certain nombre de candidats
à gauche mais aussi par jean lassalle
concernant les étudiants fabien roussel
veut également que les personnes en
alternance soit payé au moins au smic
par ailleurs fabien roussel va aller
vers le zéro jeunes au chômage et pour
ça il souhaite que chaque étudiant qui
termine ses études et une offre d'emploi
en cdi correspondant à ses compétences
et dix comme ça forcément ça paraît très
compliqué mais pour le permettre tu
adores hausse elle veut notamment rendre
obligatoire pour les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés de réserver au moins 10%
des nouvelles embauches aux jeunes de
moins de 25 ans ce qui devrait donc
encourager l'embauché des jeunes puisque
la loi obligerait ces entreprises là à
embaucher déjà quatrième mesure de
fabien roussel qui a pour objectif de
répondre à la question du financement
des mesures que je viens d'évoquer
fabien roussel veut remettre en place
l'impôt sur la fortune
c'est un pot qui concernait les français
ayant un patrimoine d'au moins 1,3
million d'euros et qui a été supprimée
par emmanuel macron lors de son mandat
pour être remplacé par l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière c'est un impôt mis
en place donc par le président de
république emmanuel macron qui ne prend
en compte que les biens immobiliers
alors le candidat communiste propose de
remettre l'impôt sur la fortune qui a
été supprimé mais au-delà de ça de
tripler le montant de cet impôt sur la
fortune c'est notamment sur cette psf x
3 co fabien roussel compte pour
permettre notamment la création des cinq
cent mille emplois dans le secteur
public ou encore plus généralement une
hausse générale des salaires cinquième
mesure fabien roussel veut que chacun
puisse bien manger alors ça peut
paraître assez bizarre dit comme ça mais
c'est un vrai combat qui le portent il
veut en fait généralisée dans tout le
pays le repas à un euro dans les
cantines scolaires en favorisant aussi
les produits bio locaux et dans son
programme la culture a aussi une place
importante
il défend une agriculture principalement
françaises à taille humaine sans
pesticides et qui garantit des prix de
base rémunérateurs pour les agriculteurs
pour cela il veut aussi interdire
l'importation de produits ne respectant
pas les normes de production française
afin d'éviter une forme de concurrence
déloyale
il veut également augmenter les
retraites agricoles pour qu'elle ne soit
pas en dessous du smic il a pour
objectif qu'il y ait cinq cent mille
agriculteurs en france d'ici à 2030
contre près de 389 1000e mans et ça
passe notamment selon lui par la
création de postes d'enseignants et
formateur agricole et plus largement un
investissement dans la recherche pour
l'agriculture on continue avec la 6e
mesure qui le distingue de tous les
autres candidats à gauche en matière
d'énergie fabien roussel veut miser sur
le nucléaire tout en continuant de
développer les énergies renouvelables
comme les éoliennes
encore l'énergie solaire selon lui il
faut miser sur le nucléaire déjà parce
que c'est une source d'énergie qui
n'émet que très peu de co2 par ailleurs
c'est une source d'énergie qui est non
intermittente c'est à dire que elle peut
fonctionner peu importe la météo et
enfin c'est selon fabien roussel et bien
une énergie qui permet à la france
d'assurer son indépendance pour sa
production d'électricité
du coup fabien roussel veut construire
six à huit réacteurs nucléaires nouvelle
génération ils se rapprochent là dessus
de la position de certains candidats
notamment emmanuel macron ou encore
marine le pen sur cette question du
nucléaire il est au contraire à gauche
jean luc mélenchon philippe poutou
yannick jadot ou encore anne hidalgo
sont tous favorables un abandon
progressif du nucléaire 7e mesures
majeures voulue par fabien roussel ça
concerne la sécurité en fait ils
accusent la gauche de ne pas assez parlé
de sécurité et de la police ou alors de
mal en parler et lui de son côté veut
créer une police nationale de proximité
de trente mille personnes en fait tu
aurais pour objectif de reconquérir
selon lui certains quartiers abandonnés
par l'état l'idée aussi c'est de recréer
un lien entre la police et la population
on notera aussi qu'ils souhaitent la
création d'une infraction spécifique
concernant les violences faites contre
les policiers il veut aussi augmenter
les salaires des policiers 8e mesures
fermes roussel veut quitter l'otan donc
l'organisation militaire de pays
d'europe et d'amérique du nord menée
principalement par les états unis en
effet pour fabien roussel la france doit
se détacher des états unis est retrouvé
davantage d'indépendance sur le plan
militaire il est même favorable à la
dissolution de l'otan et souhaite que la
france crée une nouvelle organisation
avec l'europe et ses états voisins par
ailleurs il veut également à mettre fin
aux opérations militaires françaises à
l'étranger mais aussi fermé toutes les
bases militaires françaises qui sont
présentes à l'étranger 9 la mesure
fabien roussel veut réinvestir dans les
zones rurales en france donc les
territoires qui sont un peuple et pour
cela il souhaite entre autres rouvrir
les maternités de proximité alors qu'en
20 ans 40 % d'entre elles ont fermé en
france il souhaite aussi à lutter contre
ce que l'on appelle les déserts médicaux
en faisant en sorte que tout le monde
est un établissement de santé
moins de trente minutes de transport
depuis son domicile on peut noter aussi
qu'il souhaite rouvrir des petites
lignes sncf un petit peu partout en
france justement pour ces territoires
davantage éloigné et mettre en place
aussi un plan national de rénovation et
de construction de logements dans ses
plus petites villes ou alors village
français enfin dernière mesure majeure
dont je voulais vous parler fabien
roussel veut supprimer l'élection au
suffrage universel du président de la
république peut être souhaite que le
président donc ne soit plus élus
directement par la population et qu' il
n'est plus qu'un rôle davantage de
représentants de la nation sans avoir
davantage de pouvoir un peu comme le
président que l'on peut retrouver en
allemagne en gros le pays serait
réellement diriger est gouvernée par le
premier ministre et son gouvernement et
ce même du coup premier ministre serait
d'à priori élu par l'assemblée nationale
ce serait donc une façon d'éviter que le
pouvoir soit concentré sur une seule
personne aujourd'hui donc le président
de la république il souhaite donc que
l'assemblée nationale joue un rôle plus
important dans la vie politique
française
fabien roussel vous êtes également
supprimé l'article 49 3 de la
constitution qui en gros permet
aujourd'hui aux premiers ministres de
passer en force une loi malgré l'avis
contraire de l'assemblée nationale par
ailleurs ils vont également mettre en
place un droit de pétition qui
permettrait à 500 mille citoyens de
pouvoir faire inscrire une proposition
de loi à l'ordre du jour du parlement
pour que le parlement s'en saisissent
forcément au bout de cinq cent mille
signatures et puissent discuter et voter
sur cette voie voilà ça c'était donc
pour les dix mesures principales de
fabien roussel ont tamines par quelques
mesures supplémentaires que je vais pas
vous détailler mais qui me semble
important à mentionner fabien on sait le
souhaitent la suppression de la plate
forme de sélection post-bac parcours sup
il souhaite aussi la gratuité des
transports en commun et du permis de
conduire pour les moins de 25 ans il
souhaite créer 350 mille nouveaux
logements crous destiné aux étudiants
ainsi que deux cent mille nouveaux
logements sociaux par an comme jean luc
mélenchon notamment fabien roussel doute
aussi alloué 1 milliard d'euros à la
lutte contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes
il souhaite aussi à rendre les
protections menstruel totalement
gratuite et enfin inscrire l'avortement
comme un droit fondamental dans la
constitution voilà donc pour ce
décryptage du programme de fabien
roussel
invite évidemment à vous abonner jeu
mais c'est pas encore le cas pour ne pas
louper son interview qui va paraître
dans quelques jours sur cette même
chaîne youtube et plus largement pour
découvrir les programmes et les
interviews de tous les candidats rendez
vous sur cette chaîne vous le savez déjà
un certain nombre maintenant qu'ils sont
sortis enfin je peux vous dire que sur
instagram on poste des comparaisons des
programmes des candidats sur un certain
nombre de sujets majeurs du coup
n'hésitez pas à nous suivre directement
sur instagram le nom du compte c'est
hugo décrypte voix l'écouté je crois que
j'ai tout dis prenez soin de vous
proposer à vos proches et on se dit ah
très vite